ich teste Rezepte von Jamie Oliver das
ist ein Frühstück für Könige Alter
das riecht richtig krass
ich bin wirklich verliebt in diesen
Teller
[ __ ] wir haben die Rezepte von
verschiedenen Starköchen getestet wir
hatten Gordon ramsy Frank Rosin und
natürlich darf auch Jamie Oliver nicht
fehlen ich glaube sehr sehr vielen von
euch dürfte er einen Begriff sein eigene
Fernsehshows die sogar in Deutschland
ausgestrahlt werden und wahrscheinlich
einfach einer der bekanntesten Köche der
Welt zumindest unserer Zeit bekannt ist
er für Komfort Küche die einfach immer
so einen kleinen Twist hat und auf genau
diese Twist finde ich gespannt ich bin
gespannt wie gut die Rezepte schmecken
wie leicht sie zu kochen sind und ihr
seid natürlich dabei wenn wir das ganze
austesten drei verschiedene Gerichte
haben wir vorbereitet und ich sage euch
so viel jedes einzelne hat es wirklich
in sich aber genug geredet fangen wir an
mit dem ersten Gericht und zum Frühstück
hat unser Jamie sich etwas ganz
Besonderes überlegt sind relativ
reduzierte Zutaten aber ich habe große
Lust das Ganze zu kochen und vor allem
zu essen wir haben Kartoffeln Zwiebeln
Knoblauch Chorizo Petersilie und Eier
wir machen ein Chorizo breakfast Hash es
gibt ja Hash Browns darüber kann man
sich ein bisschen herleiten worum es
geht wir arbeiten mit der Hauptzutat
Kartoffel und machen eigentlich so eine
kleine ja so eine kleine Pfanne
eigentlich fast so ein bisschen was wie
Bratkartoffeln aber ihr werdet schon
sehen erstmal Fahne an dann nähen wir
ein wenig Olivenöl und das auf unseren
Pfannenboden ich habe jetzt extra keine
von meinen beschichteten Pfannen
genommen weil die haben Plastikgriff die
kommt nämlich später in den Ofen kurz
warten dass das Öl heiß wird spricht ja
nichts dagegen dass ich meine Zwiebel
auch rein mache wenn es noch nicht heiß
ist andererseits das nicht so Set ist
fallen ich mache es trotzdem was wollt
ihr jetzt machen ich muss eine Sache
sagen wo ich jetzt stehe koche in der
neuen Küche ich habe sehr vermisst was
das erste kochvideo was wir nach Amerika
drehen und ich weiß nicht irgendwie zu
stehen ist zu riechen Eric hinter der
Kamera ist ein Traum gib jetzt den
Knoblauch dazu ich mache das ja immer
bisschen später als die Zwiebeln weil
Knoblauch schneller bitter wird weniger
lang zum Garen braucht was ehrlich sagen
so so wie bei dir so ein Joshua weiß man
oder Kenji so dich zum Kochen gebracht
haben was bei mir so ein Jamie Oliver
echt ja weil du wirklich im Fernsehen
dann die Sachen geschaut hast
geil wir geben die Chorizo dazu
[Gelächter]
das Gehirn hat dein Körper verlassen als
du diese leckere cherise gesehen hast
aber ich kann es verstehen die sieht
wirklich köstlich aus und die riecht
auch direkt die riecht super auch eine
ganz feine Sache soll ich dir alles er
sieht hier nicht mehr ganz so schlimm
aus wie die letzten Tage wir haben uns
Mühe gegeben haben ein bisschen am
Studio gearbeitet die Videos die wir
vorproduziert haben aus Amerika genutzt
ich hoffe ihr hört es ihr seht es alles
noch nicht 1000 prozentig Weg wir
arbeiten dran aber wir arbeiten ja
schaut mal hier an die Decke wie lange
hat das gedauert oder zu lange so guck
mal wie wunderbar jetzt die Zwiebeln und
der Knoblauch schon die Farbe von der
Paprika aus der Chorizo annehmen so
lieben wirst und was ich hier habe sind
vorgekochte Kartoffeln sind noch nicht
ganz durch denn wir geben jetzt noch mal
für 5 Minuten mit in unsere Pfanne das
Braten wir jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen mit an und dann kommt das ganze
in unseren Ofen der schon vorgeheizt ist
auf 180 Grad so soll das Ganze aussehen
wenn es fertig ist und die Kartoffeln
haben hier so ein bisschen so ein
leichten crisp dran und ich glaube das
liegt daran dass Jamie halt mit so einer
Eisenpfanne mit Patina arbeitet das
Problem ist meine Pfanne ist relativ neu
deshalb ist das ganze hier unten am
Boden ein bisschen angebracht ich werde
deshalb die Pfanne wie sie ist noch ohne
Eier in den Ofen stellen zack damit die
Kartoffeln ein bisschen knusprig werden
10 Minuten lasse ich das ganze jetzt
drin und erst dann mache ich mein Eier
drüber
10 Minuten später und das ganze sieht so
aus wir haben hier ein oder anderen
knusprigen Punkt schon an unseren
Kartoffeln ergattern können so aber man
hört auch schon was ich glaube das geht
in eine gute wir haben gar kein Licht an
es ist ja extra gemacht nein einmal
Setup flexen
[Musik]
so also so sieht das Ganze aus ich habe
ein gutes Gefühl wir nehmen uns unsere
Eier und schlagen die jetzt einfach
verteilt auf unserer Hash auf unserer
breakfast Hash ich finde ja Leute sagen
ja immer schlagt Eier auf einer flachen
Oberfläche auf ne aber ich finde das so
sinnlos weil
die öffne ich das Ding dann schreibt sie
mal in die Kommentare wenn ihr da
bessere Methode aber ich gehe immer auf
so eine scharfe Kante und dann
funktioniert es in der Regel eigentlich
auch wir nehmen das ganze und stellen es
in unseren Ofen der ist wieder bei 180
Grad ober Unterhitze behalten jetzt
quasi ein bisschen unsere Eier im Blick
wir möchten gerne dass das Eigelb
flüssig und das Eiweiß gestockt ist 5
bis 7 Minuten dann haben wir sie raus
garnieren das ganze und dann können wir
endlich frühstücken ich freue mich
schauen wir uns das ganze mal an Mamma
Mia das ist ein Frühstück für Könige
Alter in dem die Petersilie frisch
gehackt sagt oben drüber und das gibt
direkt alles was wir noch gebraucht
haben an Kontrast an Farbe bleibt
eigentlich nur noch übrig zu essen aber
ich habe ein bisschen Angst davor weil
ich glaube das ist so Vulkan heißt ein
Frühstück für eine ganze Familie und mit
sehr viel Hunger wird damit auf jeden
Fall sehr satt wir gucken mal ob das mit
dem Eigelb funktioniert hat
es ist ganz eigenartig das hat wie so
eine harte Hautschicht entwickelt aber
innen drin aber noch ein bisschen
flüssiges Eigelb also ich glaube das
wird nicht meine
lieblingszubereitungsart von von Ei
sondern jedoch erstmal ja guck dir das
doch mal an alter das fühlt sich total
komisch an hier damit ein bisschen
Eigelb in den Hash Brown bisschen von
unserer guck mal dieses Fett da unten ja
das Crazy also was wirklich die
Tourismus abgeben und Fett crazy wir
machen uns eine perfekte Gabel fertig
pusten halbe Stunde damit wir uns nicht
den Mund verbrennen
und dann probieren wir
wie soll es anders schmecken das ist
wirklich bei den Zutaten was eine macht
ja
auch knusprig geworden dadurch dass wir
die im Ofen hatten Hammer das setzt auf
jeden Fall die Latte schon sehr hoch
fürs Mittagessen und ich sag so viel das
habe ich noch nie gegessen das habe ich
noch nie gesehen davon habe ich noch nie
gehört und ich glaube das wird eine 10
%. was jetzt kommt darauf bin ich sehr
sehr gespannt wir haben hier Blumenkohl
Blumenkohl ist der Protagonist von
unserem Gericht wir machen nämlich eine
Blumenkohl Käse Pasta und die klingt es
auf Englisch krasser Collie flower
cheese Pasta sind sehr sehr wenige
Zutaten einfache Handgriffe und am Ende
zumindest von dem was ich gesehen habe
ein sehr sehr eindrucksvolles Ergebnis
wir haben hier den Blumenkohl bei dem
wir einfach die Blätter abdrehen wir
werden sie anders als man das gewöhnt
ist nicht wegwerfen sondern werden sie
fein hacken und mit anderen Zutaten
gemeinsam einen Topping für unsere Pasta
herstellen den Stapel können wir dann
einfach fein hacken der ist natürlich
auch essbar und ihr hört das schon beim
Schneiden der hat auch so einen gewissen
Crunch so sieht das das ganze dann aus
eine weitere Zutat für unser Topping den
zwei Knoblauchzehen und die wir
ebenfalls fein hacken werden und wenn
ihr bisher nicht wusstet was unser
Topping wird kein Problem wir brauchen
jetzt noch Brot das ist Sauerteigbrot am
Freitag gekauft über das Wochenende
trocken geworden im Ofen noch mal fertig
durch den Mixer gezogen und dann kriegt
man hier so schönes bröseliges
Sauerteigbrot und zusammen Knoblauch
Semmelbrösel blumenkohlblätter kriegen
wir pan-gratato das heißt so viel wie
geriebenes Brot auf Italienisch nur dass
das in dem Fall noch ein bisschen Spice
bekommt gegeben unser Brot ins Öl rösten
das jetzt ein bisschen an dazu kommen
unsere blumenkohlblätter mit dem
Knoblauch warte ich noch ein bisschen so
rösten wir das Ganze ein bisschen an das
schön knusprig wird
auch unseren Knoblauch geben wir rein
wie überall sparen wir nicht an Olivenöl
ich glaube allein wenn ich mir das hier
so angucke sind wir da auf einem sehr
sehr guten Weg ganz normal schön ein
bisschen beleben das Rot knusprig werden
lassen dazu so die frische Blumenkohl
und insgesamt sieht das einfach schön
aus als nächstes geben wir in unsere
Soßen Pfanne ein wenig Milch will ich
natürlich vorsichtig sein dass sie nicht
verbrennt ich glaube das sind 400 ml 400
Milliliter dann brauchen wir jetzt
wieder unseren Star den Blumenkohl dann
brauchen wir etwa die Hälfte
da muss man jetzt nicht genau arbeiten
oder irgendwas denn das was wir jetzt
herstellen kommt in den Mixer wird dann
zu einer feinen Soße püriert so Milch
kommt jetzt langsam auf Temperatur das
heißt wir können unseren Blumenkohl
schon hineingeben
ich kocht ja die Milch hoch also der
wird auf jeden Fall gleichmäßig garen
und das beste ist die Milch zieht in den
Blumenkohl ein passt da so auf Milch
Basis schon ein bisschen eigenartig eine
Sache fügen noch zu oder außergewöhnlich
besser gesagt Zwiebeln eine gehackte
Zwiebel garen wir mit in der Milch ich
weiß nicht guck mal es gibt so manche
Sachen da denkt man so jeder Italiener
würde böse werden die wäre so sauer wenn
man das macht wenn man so Pasta so kocht
kann auch sein dass sie es genauso
machen dass das so eine Uhr italienische
Pasta ist wenn alles drin ist geben wir
den Deckel drauf und lassen das Ganze so
für 15 Minuten köcheln
wir haben leider doch so eine leichte
Milchhaut hier am Pfannenboden
entwickelt ich werde probieren dass wir
die vielleicht nicht ganz mit dazu
nehmen aber erstmal geben wir unseren
Blumenkohl in den Mixer am Ende schicken
wir noch unsere Milch dazu und dann
passiert die Mix Magie so der restliche
Blumenkohl kommt auch noch rein und so
Zack und unsere Zwiebeln kommen auch
noch dazu und jetzt ist gut wenn man
einen starken Mixer hat wir wollen das
ganze nämlich jetzt zu einer homogenen
Masse durchmixen aber nicht einfach so
oder kommt noch was rein
oh mein Gott und zwar 70 Gramm von
weißem Cheddar Käse den gebe ich jetzt
einfach mal nach oben
kräftig aber ich glaube das ist relativ
wichtig für diese Pasta weil Blumenkohl
hat ja so dieses liebliche dieses diesen
soften Geschmack und dazu so ein
kräftiger Käse der das durchschneidet
hat sich der Jamie was beigebracht
[Musik]
so wie unser Endprodukt aussieht darauf
müsst ihr euch ein bisschen gedulden wir
gehen jetzt erstmal unsere baguettini in
unseren Topf mit gesalzenem Wasser und
das Kochen wir jetzt nach kotura das
sind 5 Minuten aber mal gucken was wir
hier drüben haben machen wir einmal
unseren Deckel auf
mit dem Löffel reingehen Alter riechst
du das
riecht richtig krass guck mal diese
schaumigkeit an wir sichern uns etwas
von dem guten Nudelwasser stellen uns
das an die Seite schütten die Nudeln ab
die Nudeln dann wieder in den Topf
hinein mit unserer Blumenkohl Mischung
verbinden
zack zack zack zack oh ist das gut so
ich gebe mal ein bisschen Salz daran
weil bisher hatten wir an unserer
blumenkohlsoße noch gar kein Salz
abseits des Käse Zeit deshalb halte ich
mich erstmal zurück der ist ja auch sehr
salzig noch mal ein bisschen von unserem
stärkehaltigen Nudelwasser dazu das ist
schon special Alter ich glaube wenn wir
die kurz stehen lassen ne dann bindet
das noch viel mehr die Soße darauf jetzt
schönes Pan Grado ich weiß nicht wie das
nicht krass werden kann und mein Kopf
sagt mir boah ist das ungesund weil so
viel Sahne drin ist das sieht einfach
aus wie so eine super cremige sahnepaste
aber es ist halt nicht ungesund weil das
sind Milch und Blumenkohl also wir haben
lange genug gewartet probieren wir
[Musik]
also wirklich ich mache selten Fotos von
Sachen die ich gekocht habe aber das
hier ist bildhübsch so auf dem Teller
diese Cremigkeit ich bin wirklich
verliebt in diesen Teller aber ich muss
ihn leider essen denn dafür ist er da
ich gehe einmal rein wir sehen hier
wirklich so diese Cremigkeit die sich an
den Nudeln festhält jetzt will ich nur
noch probieren
das ist so krass Blumenkohl ist ja kein
wahnsinnig intensiver Geschmack ne
dadurch schmeckt man ganz ganz ganz
deutlich zum Beispiel den Knoblauch raus
aber die Cremigkeit die der Blumenkohl
mitbringt mit diesem dezenten Geschmack
passt einfach perfekt ich sag dir
wirklich das ist so eine Schaufel Pasta
ja so die schmeckt so gut ist so einfach
auf eine sehr sehr gute Art und Weise
dass man die einfach nur so Schaufeln
will
die Cremigkeit ist wirklich sehr sehr
und Point und ich finde das krass dass
man so eine Cremigkeit mit
vergleichsweise so wenig Kalorien
erzeugen kann soweit Cremigkeit ist für
mich eigentlich Sahne und das ist ein
richtiger so ein richtiger Hack dass man
das mit mit Blumenkohl macht also crazy
muss auch probieren weißt du
aber was sagst du die die Konsistenz ist
ein absoluter Knaller oder Alter das
macht einfach
macht was mit mir falls ihr euch fragt
was jetzt passiert normalerweise jetzt
rufen wir alle und geben einen Essen
genau das machen wir jetzt Freunde es
gibt wieder essen Philipp diesmal auch
für dich kommen wir zum Abendessen zum
dritten Gericht ist heutigen Tages ich
nehme ein bisschen Butter gebe sie in
meine Pfanne dazu kommen vier klein
geschnittene Zwiebeln wenn Streifen
möchten nämlich diese klassischen
goldbraun karamellisierten Zwiebeln
herstellen und für eine Sache die mir
sehr sehr wichtig geworden ist in meinem
amerika-urlaub Mac and cheese unfassbar
lecker unfassbar ungesund aber absolutes
comfort food wahrscheinlich so das kommt
fort food bin gespannt was Jamie Oliver
daraus macht wir werden es heute auf
jeden Fall nachmachen die Zwiebel lassen
wir jetzt für 15 Minuten so stehen bis
sie perfekt goldbraun
[Musik]
man sieht direkt riecht gut und wir
haben auch direkt mehr braune Farbe dran
so sehen unsere Zwiebeln aus schön Farbe
bekommen man kann das perfektionieren
man kann so perfekte karamellisierte
Zwiebeln mit ganz viel Zeit erreichen
aber damit bin ich auf jeden Fall happy
wir geben ein wenig Mehl jetzt oben
drauf auch schon interessant hier so
Zwiebeln mit Mehl der Jamie Oliver
Klassiker und wenn das ganze dann so
aussieht nehmen wir uns unsere Milch
geben die dran
ein Liter geben wir jetzt oben drauf und
jetzt gehe ich weil ich Angst habe ein
bisschen runter mit der Temperatur und
drehe direkt ein bisschen durch so dass
ich unsere Zwiebeln wieder lösen und so
kochen wir das ganze jetzt einmal auf
hier haben wir einen Topf mit kochendem
Wasser für unsere Makkaroni die wir
jetzt direkt hineingeben werden viele
Amerikaner schwören auf genau diese
Ellbogen Makkaroni die kochen wir nicht
ganz so lange wie es auf der Packung
steht und dann ziemlich genau die Hälfte
unsere Milch ist einmal schön Temperatur
bekommen das heißt sie ist bereit den
Käse zu schmelzen den jetzt hineingeben
und das sind direkt drei verschiedene
Sorten einmal
Cheddar und einmal Grana Padano früher
anders als die Cally flower Pasta kann
man hier glaube ich keine Entschuldigung
mehr finden dass das in irgendeiner Form
gesund ist oder so aber für mich ist das
vollkommen in Ordnung ich habe nämlich
richtig Bock auf so eine cremige käsige
Explosion die kommen sie ist ein
bisschen speziell hier noch ne ist das
beim Jamie aus sein ich weiß ja nicht
und zwei spezielle beziehungsweise
zumindest besondere Zutaten verwendet
Jamie noch nämlich ich gebe euch einen
Moment zu überlegen was das hier ist
dazu brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch
Senf und das hier ist Mango Chutney ist
eine klassische Jamie Oliver Zutat man
dazu
mittelscharfer Senf dazu aber guck mal
ich weiß nicht ob ich was falsch gemacht
habe aber jetzt gerade ist das noch so
super sämig weißt du noch nicht so eine
schöne cremige Masse vielleicht
verbindet es sich ja auch erst alles
ganz am Ende in der Farbe vielleicht
auch ne unsere Nudeln sind vorgekocht
und ich schütte jetzt ein wenig von
unserem Nudelwasser weil für immer
praktisch so ein bisschen Nudelwasser zu
haben sehr sehr gut verdammt ich glaube
wir laufen gerade auf so einen kleinen
fail hinaus bei Jamie sieht das auch
anders aus irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob
die
Rezeptangaben ungenau waren aber wir
glauben wir haben zu viel zu wenig Käse
dann kommen wir jetzt mit unseren
Makkaroni und geben sie hinzu knappe
Kiste Jamie fügt auch noch ein bisschen
worcestersoße hinzu
dazu kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen
Pastawasser wir haben alles noch besten
Wissen und Gewissen gemacht es sieht
nicht verkehrt aus sieht nicht so aus
wie bei ihm aber vielleicht redet der
Ofen ja und dafür brauchen wir eine Form
und jetzt ist aufgefallen wir haben nur
diese Form hier das heißt es wird so ein
richtiges Kantinen Mac entschießt
einmal voll laden
ich bin gespannt mein Jamie Oliver hat
eh schon mein Herz gewonnen mit der
Cordi flower Pasta aber wenn das jetzt
auch noch gut wird Feierabend
wir können unsere Zeit gut einsetzen
denn wir schneiden bacon in Würfel
das sind schön knusprig werden das
werden jetzt quasi so kleine Bacon
Flakes ich bin ja eigentlich sehr großer
Fan von diesem Bacon den wir auch in
Amerika hatten zum Beispiel so knusprige
Bacon Flakes ist der Bacon den wir hier
in Deutschland bekommen perfekt im
ausgelassenen Fett posten wir wieder
Semmelbrösel an und unser Ziel vom
gesamten hier ist wieder ein schönes
Topping für unser Gesicht einfach um
noch so eine weitere Ebene von Textur
von Geschmack hinzuzufügen da weiß der
Jamie glaube ich was er macht hier ne so
muss das Aussehen du musst das klingen
du musst das Riechen und so muss auch
das Fett danach in der Pfanne ja sollen
wir schauen Leute man hört sogar schon
was
[ __ ] ist das krank
auf Crunch of Crunch
Jamie Oliver Macken cheese der Kontrast
zwischen dieser cheddarhaube den
knusprigen breadcrums und den Mac and
cheese kann sich sehen lassen weil wir
das Ganze schmeckt finden wir jetzt
heraus einmal rein durch diesen
knusprigen Deckel paar von unseren
Makkaroni es ist keine krass cremige
Soße aus nun also das muss es auch nicht
sein ich finde du bist ich sollte es
aber sein ich meine jetzt aus einer sich
da genau ich sag nicht dass sie nicht
geil sein soll sie werden vielleicht
lecker sein aber ich bin so muss man
sich wenn man das so im Restaurant
bestellen würde dann wird man trotzdem
glücklich das werden wir sehen
weiß man was mich diese erinnert und das
war sehr gutes an die Lobster macinchies
die Lukas eversmeier für mich gemacht
hat war keine Mac and cheese und mit
Panko noch mal oben drauf für den Crunch
die waren ja auch nicht so super cremig
man hat auch da so die Brotkrumen so ein
bisschen geschmeckt ich persönlich mag
es cremiger das kann auch an unserem
Ende entstanden sein der Fehler meine
ich habe alles noch Rezept gemacht aber
den Komfort food Faktor den vor allem
dieses Gericht aber alle anderen heute
auch hatten der ist da und der ist
wichtig deswegen danke noch mal an Jamie
Oliver für diese tollen Rezepte die
absolute Nummer eins die Cally flower
cheese Pasta der wirklich so gibt mir so
gib mein Horizont erweitert aber auch
alle anderen Sachen waren sehr sehr
lecker ihr könnt ja mal in die
Kommentare schreiben was für euch das
beste war was hat euch am besten
gefallen optisch und wen sollen wir als
nächstes machen wir hatten Steffen
Henssler Frank Rosin Gordon Ramsi und
jetzt Jamie Oliver den gibt es noch von
dem wir mal die Rezepte unter die Lupe
nehmen sollen hier ist ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video da kannst du gerne
drauf klicken oder auch den Kanal
abonnieren würde ich mich sehr freuen
danke fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten
Mal und bis dahin ciao